the selling Sunset Journey Begins it
does why did you want to sign yourself
up for this experience it's a really
good question I asked myself that
sometimes hold on the issue yeah is why
is it necessary for you to voice an
opinion on my family
I wouldn't talk about your family
your journey to Motherhood became a Hot
Topic how much of that were you
anticipating
uh all of it I feel like I I was pretty
prepared for it um I mean people saying
uh mean things is always you know an
uneasy thing to deal with but I expected
most of it Chelsea is kind of the most
vocal
about you yes she is
she has a lot to say she was the new
girl last year yeah do you think there
was maybe a subconscious well I've gotta
create a little drama here
maybe
um you know I won't speak for her I'm
not entirely sure what her overall issue
is or why it's gone so far but I
definitely could see the pressure of
trying to assert something in this
season maybe she didn't have a proper
storyline so she needed me but I don't
know I mean it is what it is and those
are her opinions and she's welcome to
have those spoken like a true reality
star thanks I think it's a compliment
ultimately the way I live my life is
very different to her as a Christian she
says that she can't really support your
choices because of her faith when you
learned of that what did you make of it
it's kind of comical to me to be honest
especially someone that says that they
have faith and are a Christian
I grew up it was you turn the other
cheek and we don't judge and all those
things but I mean
once again she can have whatever opinion
she wants I just wish she kept a little
bit of it to herself because we're happy
so there was also an off-camera moment
that she decided to bring on camera
so there is an issue with that for me
she pulled up her phone and she turned
it to me uh-oh it said Nick Cannon
welcomes child with Lanisha Cole she
found out right when you guys were up
yeah but that may be she didn't know
about that apparently not she was very
surprised and she was very upset and for
good reason this was like completely a
secret wow that is messy what if she
didn't know about this baby and that was
the first time she indeed found out that
is like a punch in the stomach that's
not what happened and so when it comes
to I don't know a storyline or the drama
or supporting her stance I don't really
know but for me and my honest truth was
I was in a place where I know what's
going on but I'm never going to divulge
information to anyone that's that
woman's right to be able to say that
this happened or didn't happen so when
someone asked me about it I don't know I
don't it's not my place so I think that
my lack of reaction or confirmation is
what she ran with and it became a
completely different thing that helped
her narrative and I applaud her for her
storyline but that's not actually
accurate in my reality okay because that
was going to be my follow-up didn't she
present that accurately now and if you
notice in the taping I've never I've
never asked in an interview and I've
never asked amongst the girls they're
all having you know conversations
without being present because everyone
knows I would have a lot to say and then
I had a scene with amanza that went a
little left as well
um listen I know what we're here for
we're making good TV I get it I'm a
Target but I'm entertaining so I'll just
take it
um I won't say that that situation was
100 accurate
there were questions that were asked
about child support and different things
that I don't really understand where it
came from and we were talking about
Amanda's situation and then I think it
all just made a very good story that
wasn't really there but
I mean it comes with the territory so
maybe some people had an agenda
okay knowing how everything shook out
knowing the conversations that happened
around you is there anything you would
have done differently or handled
differently
honestly no not really I think that
that's not something that I have any
control over I can't help what other
people are saying or their opinions or
how they feel or how they react to me or
the lack of reaction I give them how
they react to that so I'm just gonna
keep being me and you either hate it or
love it but
I'm not going anywhere
what would you say is the biggest
misconception about you a lot I think
that people really run with this
narrative with my partner I get it maybe
they need a way for it to make sense to
them but I'm really happy I'm really
secure I'm really I have a great life I
love my son and I love I love my partner
and you know there's not as much going
on here as people hope that there is so
we kind of let them just run with
whatever they want to say
okay
you're one of the first women on the
show to really showcase your Rolodex and
like how deep your clients go
I started
okay
do you think the other women were at all
threatened by you maybe but I think I
have a really good relationship with the
majority of them and so a lot of them
are very supportive they're all boss
women supporting each other which is
what's so great about this group but I
definitely do I do bring some some
high-end clientele and you had your
guard up a little bit there was some
friction with Emma yes you two are now
buddies yes we are so is she the person
who maybe surprised you the most or your
opinion changed the most over the course
of you know going into it I never
thought I would have had any drama with
with Emma at all but I think it was like
a random occurrence that just happened
to be my client and it panned out that
way but I honestly thought I would have
been friends with Emma so I'm glad we
ended up hashing it out
um but yeah she's really the only one I
had any tea besides
the aforementioned would Chelsea be the
person who disappointed you the most
yeah yeah I think so I think for me it
went a little too far it was a little
too personal and it you know it really
attacked my family which I feel like is
off limits regardless of doing a show or
not but
it is what it is we are getting season
seven later this year
from the sneak peek that we get at the
end of season six it is more of the
crystal versus Nicole Saga you've said
horrific things about me everything I
say about you is hold on I need to pause
right or I'm gonna end you do you
believe Chris Shell would come for
Nicole in that way
I don't personally feel like she came
for Nicole originally
um I think things escalated a little bit
but I obviously was not present for any
of these
I guess altercations arguments um so I
can't speak too much because I literally
missed all of it because I was at home
out of most of the drama so when you get
you hear little pieces of it I'm sure
yeah why do you start to put together in
your mind well first I was very confused
um but I think it just sounded like
something that came from the past that
obviously Nicole hadn't dealt with and I
think that she was a little bit
aggressive with Christian and krishelle
bit back and from someone that's feisty
I don't necessarily disagree but at the
same time
we do have to have certain boundaries
and respect for each other and that goes
both ways so
that and I guess they're gonna have to
figure that out yeah it's a little bit
of an eye for an eye yeah it was knowing
what you shot what are you most excited
to Showcase in that next chapter of the
show
I'm very excited to show my actual
personality because I feel like we only
got a little bit of it and getting to
know me and my relationships with the
clients that I have I think it's really
important for me just My overall
personality because people have an idea
of who they think I am and I'm literally
nothing like Instagram
like nothing
so I I do think that that's going to be
a really cool part of seven for sure is
there anything you're dreading making it
to TV
really just you know the drama with my
partner and Chelsea that's more of what
I'm dreading because I feel
it's not all accurate and it's you know
that's that's mainly the only thing
everything else was great